Speaker 1: Ronna McDaniel is the chair of
the Republican National Committee and she is
trying to beat off a challenge from Pillow.
Mike Pillow is challenging Ronna McDaniel
for the RNC chair. Shipp, Chairperson Shipp and
McDaniel appeared on Fox News with Stuart Varney.
And Varney, to his credit, asked a perfectly fine
question, which is, you know, it didn't go that
well for Republicans in the November 8th, 2022
midterms. Does Trump bear some responsibility
for that? And Ronna McDaniel did not like that.
Speaker 2: QUESTION Would you publicly say that
Donald Trump bears any responsibility for the some
of the losses in the midterm elections? Would you
say that? I don't like this. I don't like these
parceling out because he supported Ted Budd,
who won and he supported J.D. Vance who
won. I think there's a lot of things.
That's why I've put together and.
Speaker 1: We're going to go back
to that. That's an interesting statement or.
Speaker 2: Action report we've got to look at
Dobbs. But here's the one thing that I think
people should be talking about the amount of
ticket splitting, the amount of Republicans
that went out and voted for Republican at
the top of the ticket. Look at Arizona. The top
vote getter is a Republican. Look at Georgia.
We had eight of nine statewide races won by
Republicans. But why are Republicans going and
voting for one Republican and not the other?
Speaker 1: Because they put out uniquely
disastrous candidates, disastrous
candidates, people like Cory Lake,
people like Herschel Walker, Doug Mastriano, one
of the most disastrous possible people that they.
That's why the ticket splitting is happening.
Speaker 2: Trump has to work hard to
bring about the answer. That means turnout.
What is the question? The answer is Trump isn't.
I'm saying I'm not into the blame game
right now. I think we've got to do.
Speaker 1: She's like, we've got to figure out
why that happened. Well, here's one reason why
it might have happened. Oh, yeah, but I don't
want to be doing the blame game. You said you
want the answer, but you don't want that answer.
Speaker 2: I guess analysis. I think it's too
quick and I think you can't parcel out. Well, this
endorsement help this one and this it's the whole
message. It's what did each candidate do? What
was their turnout? But most importantly, what how
do we get independents to support Republicans?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, I say study it,
study it. But when you ask yourself, well,
why did Brian Kemp win so easily in Georgia
and Herschel Walker lost. Herschel Walker was a
uniquely disastrous candidate. And by the way,
he almost won like it. It fortunately, it didn't
happen, but he almost won the other. I mean,
listen, I don't know to what degree Ronna McDaniel
is telling us what she really believes or she has
to put on a face. Right. But McCain voters.
Are not necessarily the types of people who
are going to get behind Carrie Lake because
Trump said Vote Lake. So I don't know how you
disassociate the MAGA candidate, even if you
don't want to point to Trump specifically from
some of these decisions that took place. And they
talk about, let's do an analysis, do an analysis.
They'll never accept the analysis. If what it
points to is Trump just really messed things up,
or at least publicly they won't. We're going
to continue having this conversation because
it is a very interesting one. But I question
to what degree they honestly want the actual
answer. It seems increasingly the Republican
voters have figured out the answer because we
looked at that poll in the last segment or
the previous segment, which found that two
thirds of Republicans don't want Trump to be the
nominee. Those are pretty significant numbers.